From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。
When I was 14, I stumbled on this way of looking at the world that seemed to explain everything to me. It was contained in a book called Chariots of the Gods by a guy named Erich von Daniken. He explained this thing that had never really made sense to me about the Bible.
14岁那年，我偶然发现了一种观察世界的方式，它似乎能向我解释一切。这一切都写在一本叫《诸神的战车》的书里，作者是埃里希·冯·丹尼肯。他解释了圣经中一件让我一直无法理解的事情。
One of my problems with the Bible at that time is that the way it seemed to me was that the Bible showed this world where God was constantly doing stuff, and involved in people's lives, and going around performing miracles, things were happening all the time, and then-- it never made sense to me-- why did he just up and go? If he had such an interest, why did he just suddenly vanish from the scene?
那时我对圣经的一个困惑是，它呈现的世界里，上帝一直在采取行动，参与人们的生活，四处施行神迹，事情不断发生。但后来——这让我非常不解——他为什么就这么走了？如果他那么感兴趣，为什么突然从舞台上消失了呢？
Erich von Daniken explained why with a combination of archaeology, readings from the Bible, readings from myths, from other peoples around the world. And his argument was basically that, thousands of years ago, our planet was being regularly visited by extraterrestrial beings, and they were going around doing all sorts of stuff, healing people, flying. They were making an impression.
埃里希·冯·丹尼肯结合考古学、圣经解读以及世界各地神话的解读，解释了原因。他的论点基本上是：几千年前，地球经常有外星生物造访，他们四处做各种事情，治愈人类，飞行。他们给人留下了深刻的印象。
In those days, when I was 14, three days a week, two days after school, and then on Sunday, I attended the Baltimore Hebrew College. And when our class would be going over, for example, the story from Genesis about Abraham and Sarah, and how they miraculously had a son even though she was much too old to have a child, I would helpfully point out that that would be possible if there were space aliens around with superior medical technology.
那时候，我14岁，每周去三天巴尔的摩希伯来学院，放学后去两天，再加上周日。当我们班讨论比如《创世记》里亚伯拉罕和撒拉的故事，讲他们如何奇迹般地生了一个儿子，尽管她年纪太大已经不能生育了，我会乐于助人地指出：如果有拥有高等医疗技术的外星人在场，那是可能的。
And I talked about these theories so passionately and so persistently that finally it got me kicked out of class. I was sent downstairs to the main office, where I had to talk to the guy who ran the Hebrew College, Rabbi Smoler.
我谈论这些理论时如此热情且坚持不懈，最终导致我被赶出了教室。我被送到楼下的办公室，必须和希伯来学院的负责人斯莫勒拉比谈话。
Rabbi Smoler's office I remember as this dimly lit place, lit by lamps, with books everywhere, and these big, comfortable chairs. And he was this man who was just smart and funny, and I have to say, completely bemused by the chance to engage a ninth-grader in a substantive discussion of these issues. And as I remember, I went down there fairly regularly for a while. And by the time he was done with me, I no longer believed the arguments from Chariots of the Gods.
我记得斯莫勒拉比的办公室是一个光线昏暗的地方，灯火通明，到处都是书，还有宽大舒适的椅子。他是一个既聪明又风趣的人，我必须说，他完全被这个机会所吸引，乐于与一名九年级的学生就这些问题进行实质性的讨论。据我所记，有一段时间我相当经常去那里。到他跟我谈完时，我不再相信《诸神的战车》里的论点了。
The problem was, I also no longer believed in God. Something had happened where Chariots of the Gods had kind of been like an occupying army in my head that had killed off the army that was God's army. And then when Rabbi Smoler came in and killed off the Chariots of Gods army, there was just basically nothing left. I was basically a blank slate. I was a clean blackboard.
问题是，我也不再相信上帝了。发生了一些事情，《诸神的战车》就像我脑中的一支占领军，杀死了上帝的那支军队。当斯莫勒拉比进来，杀死了《诸神的战车》那支军队后，基本上就什么都没剩下。我基本上成了一张白纸。我成了一块干净的黑板。
And I have never found again any kind of religious faith. Since the time I was 14, I just don't believe in God.
我再也没有找到任何宗教信仰。从14岁那年起，我就不相信上帝了。
Every now and then, someone who I'm close to who's Christian tries to tell me about Jesus. Whenever that happens, I've taken it very seriously. And I have heard them out, and I have looked at the Bible. And every time it's happened, it's come down to this, that I find that I don't seem to have a choice over whether or not I believe in God. I simply find that I do not. And trying to force myself to believe, it would be like trying to convince yourself that you're in love with somebody who you're not in love with. Either you have faith or you don't. Either you believe or you don't. Your belief finds you, and then you and it have each other. And once your faith is set, I think only the biggest kind of seismic event in your life can change that, even if you want to change it.
偶尔，我身边亲近的基督徒会试着跟我讲耶稣。每当发生这种情况时，我都非常认真地对待。我倾听了他们，也看过圣经。每一次发生这种情况，结果都归结为一点：我发现自己似乎没有选择，无法决定是否相信上帝。我只是发现我并不相信。强迫自己相信，就像试图说服自己去爱一个你不爱的人一样。要么你有信仰，要么没有。要么你相信，要么不信。信仰会找到你，然后你与它互相拥有。一旦你的信仰确定下来，我认为只有生活中最重大的震荡性事件才能改变它，即使你想改变它。
Well, today on our radio program, in this Christmas season, we bring you stories of people who are stuck in one kind of faith or another, for better or worse, and what happens because of their faith, or lack of it. Act One of our show, Adventures In Turning the Other Cheek. In that act, we ask the question, how do Christians and Muslims get along in the place where you would think they would get along worse than anywhere, in modern day Afghanistan? And when they talk about religion together, what do they talk about?
好了，在今天的广播节目中，在这个圣诞季，我们为你带来一些被困在某种信仰中的人们的故事，无论好坏，以及因为他们的信仰或缺乏信仰而发生的事情。我们节目的第一幕，“左右脸颊的故事”。在那一幕中，我们提出了一个问题：在那个你认为基督徒和穆斯林最难相处的地方——当今的阿富汗，他们是如何相处的？当他们谈论宗教时，他们谈论什么？
Act Two, Does Size Matter If You're Talking About a Cross? In that story, we visit the largest cross in the Western hemisphere, and we find out that, actually, the answer to that question is, yes, size does matter if you're talking about a cross.
第二幕，“谈论十字架时，大小重要吗？”在那个故事中，我们参观了西半球最大的十字架，并发现，实际上，那个问题的答案是：是的，如果你谈论的是十字架，大小确实很重要。
Act Three, The Epiphany Biz, the story of what it means to be a secular person whose job is documenting miracles for Christians.
第三幕，“顿悟生意”，讲述了一个世俗的人，工作却是为基督徒记录神迹的故事。
Act Four, First Be Reconciled To Thy Brother, and Then Come and Offer Thy Gift. In that act, an all-black church gets a white minister who has different ideas than they have about what it means to worship God, whiter ideas, in their view. Why they've kept him for 15 years, despite that. Stay with us.
第四幕，“先与你的弟兄和好，然后来献你的礼物”。在那一幕中，一个全黑人教堂来了一位白人牧师，他对崇拜上帝有着与他们不同的想法，在他们看来，是更“白人化”的想法。尽管如此，为什么他们还是留了他15年。请继续收听。
Act One, Adventures In Turning the Other Cheek.
第一幕，左右脸颊的故事。
Georg Taubmann is uniquely situated to explain how Christians and Muslims get along in a place where you might think that they wouldn't get along at all. For 17 years, he's built houses and done other relief work in Afghanistan as part of a Christian missionary group called Shelter Now. He speaks Pashtun, has got to know hundreds of Afghanis over the years.
格奥尔格·陶布曼处于一个独特的境地，能够解释基督徒和穆斯林如何在那个你可能认为他们根本无法相处的地方相处。17年来，作为名为“避难所”的基督教传教组织的一部分，他在阿富汗建造房屋并从事其他救援工作。他会说普什图语，多年来结识了数百名阿富汗人。
A month before the World Trade Center attack, Georg Taubmann was one of eight Westerners imprisoned by the Taliban. They were captives for three months before they were rescued.
在世界贸易中心袭击事件前一个月，格奥尔格·陶布曼是八名被塔利班监禁的西方人之一。他们在获救前被俘虏了三个月。
He's back now in his home country, Germany. And he says that it was usually easier to talk about god in Taliban-controlled Afghanistan-- a country run by fundamentalist Muslims-- than it usually is in Germany or in the United States.
他现在回到了他的家乡德国。他说，在塔利班控制下的阿富汗——一个由原教旨主义穆斯林管理的国家——谈论上帝，通常比在德国或美国更容易。
Contrary to our societies where we come from, it is a very natural thing in Afghanistan to talk about your faith. And we have plenty of opportunities, because people are a religious people, and if you get to know somebody, it doesn't take usually a long time that you speak about this also.
与我们所来自的社会相反，在阿富汗谈论你的信仰是一件非常自然的事情。我们有很多机会，因为那里的人民是有宗教信仰的，如果你认识某人，通常不需要很长时间就会谈到这一点。
Most often would you bring it up, or would they bring it up?
大多数情况下是你提出来的，还是他们提出来的？
In most of the cases, they bring it up. Even while we were in prison with the Taliban, they came and they saw us reading our Bible. They said, oh, what is that? We said, this is the Holy Injil. Oh! And then they wanted to see it, and they talked about it. And you know, immediately they involved us in conversations.
大多数情况下，是他们提出来的。即使在我们被塔利班关押期间，他们也会过来看到我们读圣经。他们说，噢，那是什么？我们说，这是神圣的《引支勒》（福音书）。噢！然后他们想看，并谈论它。你知道，他们立即让我们参与了对话。
What would you say? How would you explain Christianity there?
你会说什么？你在那里怎么解释基督教？
Well, often there's some misconceptions about us Christians. Often when they look at us Christians, like Muslims who have been in the West, they say, you people, we never see you praying. You know, we don't even know whether you're praying. You know? Like you see, their prayers is very much in public, you know?
嗯，人们对我们基督徒常有一些误解。当他们看着我们这些基督徒时，就像在西方的穆斯林一样，他们会说，你们这些人，我们从没见过你们祈祷。你知道，我们甚至不知道你们是否在祈祷。你知道吗？就像你看到的，他们的祈祷是非常公开的，你知道吗？
And they don't see people, like in Muslim countries, where you see them reading the Koran. So they often think that we Christians, we don't even have holy books, or we don't read them.
而且他们不像在穆斯林国家那样看到人们阅读《古兰经》。所以他们常认为我们基督徒甚至没有圣书，或者我们不读它们。
And of course, they see a lot of immorality in our countries. You know, sex films being shown on TV, and young people just living together without being married. And they think, well, that's maybe part of our Christian culture.
当然，他们在我们国家看到了很多不道德的行为。你知道，电视上播放色情电影，年轻人未婚同居。他们认为，好吧，那可能是我们基督教文化的一部分。
And they think that Christianity sanctions that, because these things are happening in a Christian country.
他们认为基督教认可这些，因为这些事情发生在基督教国家。
They see a lot of these things happening, and so they think all Christians are like this.
他们看到很多这样的事情发生，所以他们认为所有基督徒都是这样。
Talking to you, I'm reminded of this story that I once heard about-- there's a German Jewish filmmaker named Marcel Ophuls, who in the last part of his career in the 1960s made a number of films, documentaries-- The Sorrow and the Pity, The Memory of Justice-- where he was interviewing the Nazi high command from World War II. And he would make these films, and people would ask him, how did he feel, as a German Jew, interviewing these former members of the Nazi high command, the ones who had survived? Wasn't it uncomfortable for him? And he would say, like, no, it wasn't. He said he found, in fact, that he had more in common with them than he had with most people, because they were both interested in history. They were both interested in the past.
和你交谈时，我想起了曾经听过的一个故事——有一位德国犹太电影制作人叫马塞尔·奥菲尔斯，他在20世纪60年代职业生涯的后期制作了几部纪录片——《悲伤与怜悯》、《正义的记忆》——他在采访二战中的纳粹最高指挥部。他会制作这些电影，人们会问他，作为一个德国犹太人，采访这些纳粹最高指挥部的幸存前成员，他感觉如何？对他来说不舒服吗？他会说，不，并不。事实上，他发现他和他们比与大多数人更有共同点，因为他们都对历史感兴趣。他们都对过去感兴趣。
And I was wondering if there's any element of that in your dealings with Muslims in Afghanistan. That, in a certain way, for somebody who has organized his life around religion, that there's some kind of understanding that one would have with anyone else who has completely organized his life or her life around religion in a way that secular people would be outside of?
我在想，你在与阿富汗穆斯林的交往中是否有类似的成分。即在某种程度上，对于一个围绕宗教组织生活的人来说，与任何其他完全围绕宗教组织生活的人之间，是否有一种世俗人所没有的某种理解？
Yes. Yeah, there are things where we understand them and they understand us, where there are things in common in a lot of areas in our lives. And often, when they see us and get to know us-- and I have seen this amongst a lot of the prisoners, when they watched our lives very closely; you know, they were living with us-- they said, oh, in many ways, you are completely different, you're also like us. And they respected that.
是的。是的，有些事情我们理解他们，他们也理解我们，在我们生活的许多领域都有共同之处。而且通常，当他们看到我们并了解我们时——我在许多囚犯中看到过这一点，当他们非常密切地观察我们的生活时；你知道，他们和我们住在一起——他们说，噢，在很多方面，你们完全不同，但你们也像我们。他们尊重这一点。
And many times, secular people-- Let me just tell you. Maybe [UNINTELLIGIBLE], but let me tell you. This one time I was going to apply for funds, and these organizations, these were Western. It was a Western organization, donor organization. No, no, we'll never give money to you, because you're a Christian agency and Afghans don't like you.
而且很多时候，世俗的人——让我告诉你。也许[听不清]，但让我告诉你。有一次我去申请资金，这些组织是西方的。这是一个西方组织，捐赠组织。不，不，我们绝不会给你钱，因为你是基督教机构，阿富汗人不喜欢你。
I said, let me tell you one thing. I said, we are Christians. We believe in one God. And they say they believe in four books, and we believe in three of them. And they know that we pray, and that we have certain moral standards. In fact, Afghans like us very much. They respect us for that. And I said, if you don't believe in God, they will not appreciate that. If you're an atheist, they will say, well, he's a kafir, definitely. You're like the Russians, who had no faith. And so he quickly changed his subject.
我说，让我告诉你一件事。我说，我们是基督徒。我们相信一位上帝。他们说他们相信四本书，我们相信其中的三本。他们知道我们祈祷，我们有特定的道德标准。事实上，阿富汗人非常喜欢我们。他们因此尊重我们。我说，如果你不相信上帝，他们不会欣赏这一点。如果你是无神论者，他们会说，好吧，他绝对是个“卡菲尔”（不信道者）。你就像俄国人，他们没有信仰。所以他很快改变了话题。
And this is what a lot of people do not understand. I mean, if we come as Christians, they know we are believers, that we believe in God, and we believe in our holy books, and we have certain moral values that, in fact, a lot of these people highly appreciate that. And even a lot of the Taliban, they appreciate this about us.
这就是许多人所不理解的。我的意思是，如果我们以基督徒身份到来，他们知道我们是信徒，我们相信上帝，我们相信我们的圣书，我们有特定的道德价值观，事实上，许多这些人非常欣赏这一点。甚至许多塔利班成员也欣赏我们这一点。
How do you know that they appreciated it? What are you talking about?
你怎么知道他们欣赏这一点？你在说什么？
Well, they did tell us. I mean, when I was in prison, so many of the Taliban came and talked with us, and discussed-- they challenged us. They watched us every day, and they said, you're a very godly people.
好吧，他们确实告诉了我们。我的意思是，当我在监狱里时，很多塔利班成员过来和我们交谈，讨论——他们挑战我们。他们每天观察我们，说，你们是非常敬虔的人。
They said this many times about our ladies. They said, we've watched these ladies, and they're different than others. We have seen many other foreigners, and the way they behaved, and what they have done, and so on and so on. And they said, we're amazed about them.
他们多次谈到我们的女士。他们说，我们观察了这些女士，她们和其他人不同。我们见过许多其他外国人，他们的行为举止，他们所做的事情，等等等等。他们说，我们对她们感到惊讶。
When the Taliban would challenge you, what would they say?
当塔利班挑战你时，他们会说什么？
Sorry?
对不起？
You said the Taliban would challenge you. What would they say? What did they ask?
你说塔利班会挑战你。他们会说什么？他们问了什么？
Usually they said, well, why are you not Muslims? Why don't you become Muslims, and why don't you believe in our books?
通常他们说，好吧，你们为什么不是穆斯林？你们为什么不成为穆斯林，为什么不相信我们的书？
What would you say?
你会说什么？
Well, I have in my faith everything that I will desire. The Bible speaks very clearly how I can have forgiveness of my sins. It shows us that when we follow Jesus, that we have eternal life.
嗯，我在我的信仰中拥有我所渴望的一切。圣经非常清楚地说明了我如何获得罪的赦免。它向我们展示了当我们跟随耶稣时，我们拥有永生。
And did that answer satisfy them, or did they still feel that you would be better off Muslim?
那个回答满足了他们吗，还是他们仍然觉得你成为穆斯林会更好？
It depends. Of course, then the discussions went on and on and on. They said, well, our book also says that if you do this and this and this, you will go to heaven. But still, there is that uncertainty in their faith. And judgment. Maybe they will not. Maybe they had done something. And I said, well, Jesus, what he promised me is, if I repent and ask for forgiveness, that he will forgive my sins. And he has done that, and I know it in my heart. And they say, well, Jesus cannot do that. He cannot just forgive your sins. He cannot do that. Only Allah can do that. And you will see this on Judgment Day, whether he forgives you or not. I said, why should I now follow again another religion where again, I have to follow all the strict commandments and all the strict rules, and at the end, and I'm not even sure whether God will forgive me? I want to stay in my faith. I found really everything that I need.
这取决于情况。当然，讨论还在继续。他们说，嗯，我们的书也说，如果你做这个、这个和那个，你就会上天堂。但仍然，他们的信仰中存在那种不确定性。还有审判。也许他们不会。也许他们做过什么事情。我说，好吧，耶稣向我承诺的是，如果我悔改并请求宽恕，他就会宽恕我的罪。他已经这样做了，我心中知道这一点。他们说，嗯，耶稣做不到。他不能就这样宽恕你的罪。他做不到。只有安拉能做到。到了审判日，你就会看到他是否宽恕你。我说，为什么我现在要再次跟随另一个宗教，在那里我不得不遵循所有严格的诫命和所有严格的规则，而最后，我甚至不确定上帝是否会宽恕我？我想留在我的信仰中。我确实找到了我所需要的一切。
Georg Taubmann, talking to us from Germany. He hopes to resume his work with Shelter Now in Afghanistan within the next few months.
格奥尔格·陶布曼，在德国与我们交谈。他希望在接下来的几个月内恢复他在阿富汗“避难所”的工作。
Act Two, Does Size Matter If You're Talking About a Cross?
第二幕，谈论十字架时，大小重要吗？
This is the story of another man stuck in his faith, acting on his faith, in this case by building a big cross, the biggest in the Western hemisphere, in fact, 45 miles east of Amarillo, Texas. Josh Noel went there with This American Life producer Alex Blumberg. Here's Josh.
这是另一个被困在信仰中的人的故事，践行着他的信仰，在这个案例中，是通过建造一个大十字架，事实上是西半球最大的十字架，在得克萨斯州阿马里洛以东45英里处。乔什·诺埃尔与《美国生活》制片人亚历克斯·布隆伯格去了那里。这是乔什。
From 20 miles away, the tallest cross in the Western hemisphere doesn't quite look like a cross. It looks more like a mutant telephone pole, just whiter and shinier. But as you speed along Interstate 40, past the wide farms and grassy plains of the Texas panhandle, the cross just keeps growing larger and larger until it's twice the height of a telephone pole, then four times the height, then eight times. And because you can't tell exactly how far away it is, at some point you begin to wonder just how tall it's going to get, standing out there in the middle of the unrelenting flatness under a wide blue sky and thick cotton ball clouds.
从20英里外看，西半球最高的十字架看起来并不完全像个十字架。它看起来更像一根变异的电线杆，只是更白、更闪亮。但当你沿着40号州际公路疾驰，经过得克萨斯狭长地带广阔的农场和草地平原时，十字架不断地变大，直到它变成电线杆高度的两倍，然后是四倍，然后是八倍。而且因为你无法准确判断它离你有多远，在某个时刻，你会开始好奇它到底会长到多高，矗立在那里，在宽阔的蓝天和厚厚的棉花糖般的云层下，在那片无情的平地上。
The tallest cross in the Western hemisphere is 190 feet tall, the height of a 19-story building. It's 12 feet across at the base. There's one bigger cross on the planet. It's in Madrid, and was built by Francisco Franco, a Fascist dictator.
西半球最高的十字架有190英尺高，相当于19层楼的高度。底座有12英尺宽。地球上还有一个更大的十字架。它在马德里，是由法西斯独裁者弗朗西斯科·佛朗哥建造的。
But here in America, we turn to the private sector for this sort of thing. A 52-year-old man named Steve Thomas decided to build it a few years back while driving past a gigantic strip club.
但在美国，我们把这类事情交给私营部门。一位名叫史蒂夫·托马斯的52岁男子几年前在开车经过一家巨大的脱衣舞俱乐部时决定建造它。
A triple-x establishment was on I-40, east of Amarillo. Three huge silos standing 30, 40 feet, triple x's everywhere, and flashing. I thought, gosh, around the country, everywhere you look, Satan has all the advertising. He's got the jump on the gun there. And I thought, gosh, why can't we outdo that? There's got to be a way we can advertise for Jesus in a much more grand way.
阿马里洛以东的I-40公路上有一家3X场所。三个巨大的筒仓，高30、40英尺，到处都是3X标志，而且还在闪烁。我想，天哪，放眼全国，无论你往哪里看，撒旦拥有所有的广告。他在那方面抢占了先机。我想，天哪，我们为什么不能胜过它？一定有一种方法能以一种更宏大的方式为耶稣做广告。
So I prayed to the Lord for about six months thinking I was going to build a billboard. And after six months of trying to do it my way, through a billboard, he gave me a vision of a cross. And  I mean, I just knew right then and there that the huge cross was what I was going to do.
所以我向主祈祷了大约六个月，认为我要建造一个广告牌。在尝试用我的方式通过广告牌做这件事六个月后，他给了我一个十字架的异象。我是说，那一刻我就知道巨大的十字架就是我要做的事情。
For most of us, such a vision would present logistical problems. But fortunately for the Lord, Steve Thomas is both a structural engineer and a millionaire, having made his fortune in the oil business.
对我们大多数人来说，这样的异象会带来后勤问题。但幸运的是，史蒂夫·托马斯既是一位结构工程师，又是一位百万富翁，他在石油行业积累了财富。
The cross is built out of white corrugated steel, the kind they use for industrial warehouses, and took 250 welders eight months to assemble. The day they poured the foundation, sales of ready-mix concrete came to a stop in the Texas panhandle.
十字架是用白色瓦楞钢建造的，就是工业仓库用的那种，用了250名焊工八个月的时间才组装完成。浇筑地基的那天，得克萨斯狭长地带的预拌混凝土销售陷入了停滞。
In all, the cross cost Steve half a million dollars, but he says he would have spent more and built even taller if objects higher than 200 feet hadn't been subject to FAA regulation. Steve didn't want the government involved with his cross.
总共，这个十字架花费了史蒂夫五十万美元，但他说，如果高于200英尺的物体不受FAA（联邦航空局）规章约束的话，他会花更多的钱，建得更高。史蒂夫不想让政府参与到他的十字架中。
The cross is so big that it can be hard to pray in front of. Because it's built of corrugated steel, you sort of feel like you're worshipping at the side of a grain silo. Instead, most people pray at smaller statues of Jesus that stand in a circle around the base of the cross, or at a life-size rendition of the crucifixion. There's a marble headstone in which a pair of hands cradle a tiny fetus, which is also very popular.
十字架太大了，在它面前很难祈祷。因为它是用瓦楞钢建造的，你感觉就像在粮仓旁边崇拜一样。相反，大多数人在十字架底部周围一圈较小的耶稣雕像前祈祷，或者在真人大小的钉十字架像前祈祷。那里有一块大理石墓碑，上面有一双手托着一个微小的胎儿，也非常受欢迎。
The atmosphere is quiet and surprisingly church-like for something that's next to a highway. We spent two days at the cross to see if Steve's initial plan was working, to see if the cross was tempting people toward God the way a triple-x theater might tempt people into sin. But in two days, we saw no conversions. If Steve's idea was that the cross had the power to call people from the highway to God, it seems to work best with people who have already heard that call, like a bunch of guys covered in tattoos who climb out of a van on their way home to Chicago from a church retreat in California.
气氛很安静，对于一个在高速公路旁的东西来说，出奇地有教堂的感觉。我们在十字架旁待了两天，看看史蒂夫最初的计划是否奏效，看看十字架是否像3X剧院可能诱使人们犯罪那样诱使人们走向上帝。但在两天里，我们没有看到任何皈依者。如果史蒂夫的想法是十字架有力量将人们从高速公路上呼唤到上帝面前，它似乎对那些已经听到那种呼唤的人效果最好，比如一群满身纹身的家伙，在从加州的一次教堂务虚会回芝加哥的路上，从面包车里爬出来。
We're all ex-gang members, ex-drug addicts, touched and transformed by the power of Jesus Christ.
我们都是前帮派成员，前吸毒者，被耶稣基督的力量触动和改变了。
About a dozen church members from Rocky, Oklahoma jump out of their van, huddled for a minute, and then just started singing.
大约十二名来自俄克拉荷马州罗基的教会成员从他们的面包车里跳出来，围拢了一分钟，然后就开始唱歌。
[SINGING]
[唱歌]
There aren't many public places where people can just climb out of a car and burst into song, but we saw this happen twice.
没有什么公共场所可以让人们直接从车里爬出来并突然开始唱歌，但我们看到这种情况发生了两次。
[SINGING]
[唱歌]
A man from Alpine, Arizona makes a monthly drive to a cancer clinic in Tulsa, Oklahoma, the only place able to treat his rare liver cancer. He usually stops at the cross on the way to Oklahoma, but not on the way back.
一名来自亚利桑那州阿尔派恩的男子每月开车去俄克拉荷马州塔尔萨的癌症诊所，那是唯一能治疗他罕见肝癌的地方。他通常在去俄克拉荷马的路上在十字架旁停留，但回来的路上不会。
Because of the chemotherapy and things that they do there, I'm generally feeling too bad to-- I want to get home as soon as I can. And any little jolt, bump in the road, man, you can feel it. I'll guarantee you.
因为他们在那里进行的化疗和治疗，我通常感觉太糟了——我想尽快回家。任何一点震动，路上的颠簸，伙计，你都能感觉到。我向你保证。
Yeah, I'm sure.
是啊，我敢肯定。
My name's Burton Kennedy. I'm from North Carolina. I'm a long haul truck driver.
我叫伯顿·肯尼迪。我来自北卡罗来纳州。我是一名长途卡车司机。
My name's Greg Talese, and I'm from Phoenix, Arizona, and I'm a truck driver.
我叫格雷格·塔利斯，我来自亚利桑那州凤凰城，我是一名卡车司机。
My name's Ricky Martin and I drive a truck.
我叫里奇·马丁，我开卡车。
There are a lot of truck drivers here. Ricky Martin drove by the cross a bunch of times before he finally stopped.
这里有很多卡车司机。里奇·马丁在最终停下来之前，开车经过十字架很多次。
I was real upset over everything that was going on with my family. My mother's up in her 80s, and I was real worried that she didn't have no way of taking care of herself up in her golden years. So I was real upset, couldn't drive. And when I left here, I was totally at ease. And I just kind of went, wow, maybe there is something to this place.
我对家里发生的一切感到非常不安。我母亲80多岁了，我非常担心她在黄金岁月里没法照顾自己。所以我非常不安，开不了车。当我离开这里时，我完全放松了。我只是有点觉得，哇，也许这个地方有什么名堂。
At peak times-- weekends during the summer-- 2,000 people a day visit the cross. A lot of them are just tourists passing through, stopping quickly to take a look. But most use the cross for some sort of quiet moment with God. For some people-- not many-- the cross is an actual destination. They head onto the highway planning to show up here.
高峰时期——夏季周末——每天有2000人参观十字架。他们中很多人只是过往的游客，匆匆停下来看一眼。但大多数人利用十字架与上帝进行某种安静的时刻。对一些人来说——不多——十字架是一个真正的目的地。他们驱车上路，计划着来到这里。
I'm Shannon Berry from Levelland, Texas. This is my wife, Linda Berry. We're newlyweds. This is our honeymoon trip.
我是来自得克萨斯州莱维兰的香农·贝里。这是我的妻子琳达·贝里。这是我们的蜜月旅行。
Considering how Shannon and Linda met, it's no surprise they decided there was no better place for their honeymoon. They first spotted each other at a gospel festival and were later introduced by friends at a Memorial Day cookout.
考虑到香农和琳达相遇的方式，难怪他们决定没有比这里更好的蜜月地点了。他们第一次见到对方是在一个福音音乐节上，后来由朋友在阵亡将士纪念日的野餐会上介绍认识。
And we went out and had coffee. And what was strange about having coffee after the cookout was that we sat down on the sofa and we started talking, and before long, we were praying. And I mean, we got into prayer so hard that the first time I'd ever had the Holy Spirit in me. I thought I knew Jesus. You know, I thought I knew Jesus. But I didn't. I found Jesus Christ that night.
我们出去喝了咖啡。在野餐后喝咖啡奇怪的地方在于，我们坐在沙发上开始交谈，没过多久，我们就开始祈祷了。我是说，我们祈祷得如此投入，以至于那是我第一次感受到圣灵进入我体内。我以为我了解耶稣。你知道，我以为我了解耶稣。但我没有。那天晚上我找到了耶稣基督。
Shannon just let go of my hand and got on his hands and knees and started crying. And he knew immediately he had the Holy Spirit.
香农松开了我的手，跪在地上开始哭泣。他立刻就知道他拥有了圣灵。
It's just like going from hot to cold. It's just the cold chill you feel all over your body. It's not like anything you've ever felt before. You can tell.
就像从热到冷一样。这只是你全身感到的那阵冷颤。这不像你以前感受到的任何东西。你可以看得出来。
He knew immediately he had it. And--
他立刻就知道他拥有它。而且——
We shared it with the whole trailer park that night. We went outside and we asked the Holy Spirit to go into every place we could see. It was--
那天晚上我们和整个拖车公园分享了它。我们走到外面，请求圣灵进入我们能看到的每一个地方。它是——
Float it right in. Waved it right into each house. And of course I had the Holy Ghost, so I have the tongues. So I started praying in tongues, and then I started giggling, and I couldn't stop giggling. And I mean, it was like 2 o'clock and Shannon kept saying, "Oh! I feel it again. I just feel it again and I feel it again!"
让它漂浮进去。把它挥进每一户人家。当然，我拥有圣灵，所以我拥有方言。所以我开始用方言祈祷，然后我开始咯咯笑，我无法停止咯咯笑。我是说，那时是两点钟，香农不停地说：“噢！我又感觉到了。我只是又感觉到了，我又感觉到了！”
It was beautiful. It was beautiful.
那太美了。那太美了。
And it was already 2 o'clock, and he had to go all the way to Levelland.
而且那时已经两点钟了，他必须一路赶回莱维兰。
After a first date like that, it seemed pretty clear they had to get married.
经历了那样的第一次约会后，很明显他们必须结婚了。
I knew it. With the second date, I did. I asked her then.
我知道。第二次约会时，我就知道了。我当时就向她求婚了。
Today is nine weeks that we've known each other.
今天是我们要认识的第九周。
Shannon and Linda sit in front of one of the statues at the base of the cross and pray that their marriage will be everything it should be, everything God wants it to be.
香农和琳达坐在十字架底座的一尊雕像前，祈祷他们的婚姻将成为它应该成为的样子，成为上帝希望它成为的样子。
In two days at the cross, the only person we talked to who didn't already have a heavy-duty kind of faith working for them was a college student named Heather. She was 20 years old, with a pierced navel, and driving a heavily-loaded pickup truck. She was traveling with her cat, a kitten named Tinsel, on her way from San Diego to Oklahoma City.
在十字架旁的这两天，我们交谈过的唯一一个本身没有深厚信仰支撑的人是一个名叫希瑟的大学生。她20岁，肚脐上打着孔，开着一辆装得满满的皮卡车。她带着她的猫，一只名叫“锡箔”的小猫，从圣地亚哥前往俄克拉荷马城。
Oh, I have school waiting for me, and a job. I work at Hooters. So I've got to go out there and deal with that.
噢，我有学业等着我，还有一份工作。我在“猫头鹰餐厅”工作。所以我必须去那里处理那些事情。
As fate would have it, Heather happened to be driving by the second-largest cross on the planet just a few days after deciding she needed a big change in her life.
命运使然，希瑟刚好在决定自己生活中需要一个大改变几天后，开车经过了这个星球上第二大十字架。
OK, I was at a bonfire with my friends. And you know, I'm sure it's well-known knowledge that almost everybody in California smokes pot and drinks beer, and like, you know, we're flakes or whatnot. And we're all hanging out and partying.
好吧，我和朋友们在篝火旁。你知道，我相信大家都知道，加州的几乎每个人都抽大麻、喝啤酒，而且我们像，你知道，我们是怪胎什么的。我们都在闲逛和聚会。
And it suddenly hit me, when all my friends-- like, none of them have any intentions of growing up. I was telling them, I'm leaving California. I'm going to quit doing the party scene. I was called "Queen of the Bonfires" because I had about four bonfires a week, or sometimes more.
当我的所有朋友——比如，他们都没有任何长大的打算——突然间，这击中了我。我告诉他们，我要离开加州。我要戒掉聚会生活。我被称为“篝火女王”，因为我每周会有四次篝火，有时甚至更多。
But I know I upset them that night because of the things that I was saying about how you're not going to grow up. I've seen my mom does drugs still to this day. You know what I mean? So that bothers me. I don't like it when parents are doing drugs. Parents should not be doing drugs. And especially if their kids are sitting around, watching. And having their kids get them a beer, what kind of crap is that? If I-- oh, sorry.
但我知道那天晚上我让他们不高兴了，因为我说的话，关于你们不会长大的事。我见过我妈妈至今仍在吸毒。你知道我的意思吗？所以我很困扰。我不喜欢父母吸毒。父母不应该吸毒。特别是如果他们的孩子坐在旁边看。而且让孩子给他们拿啤酒，那算什么垃圾事？如果我——噢，对不起。
So all this is on her mind as she speeds along Interstate 40 in the middle of nowhere.
所以所有这些都在她脑子里，当她在这荒郊野外沿着40号州际公路飞驰时。
You know, driving along the road, I haven't thought about Jesus much, or God much. I haven't found myself praying or thanking God for anything, until I saw the cross, until I pulled over. And over there, I had to touch his face over there, and I got a really, really good feeling by just touching the statues.
你知道，开车在路上，我没怎么想过耶稣，或者上帝。我没发现自己在为任何事祈祷或感谢上帝，直到我看到十字架，直到我靠边停车。在那里，我不得不摸摸在那边的他的脸，仅仅是通过触摸雕像，我就得到了一种非常、非常好的感觉。
Heather points at one of the statues of Jesus that circle the cross.
希瑟指着环绕十字架的耶稣雕像之一。
What did you see in the expression on Jesus's face on the statue? I mean, why did you want to touch it?
你在雕像中耶稣的脸上看到了什么？我的意思是，为什么你想摸它？
There's not so much as, like, pain in his face, but just kind of disappointment a little bit, or hurt, kind of like-- I don't know. It looks almost like he blames himself. In the statue, what I get is that he was blaming himself at that moment, because he failed or-- or not failed, technically, but there's just something in his face, like he felt really bad at that time. He's human there. He's totally human. And it just kind brings you back that God's not so far away. He's right there.
他的脸上不仅仅是痛苦，而是有点失望，或者受伤，有点像——我不知道。它看起来几乎像是他责怪自己。在雕像里，我得到的是他在那一刻责怪自己，因为他失败了——或者不是失败，从技术上讲，但他的脸上确实有什么东西，就像他当时感觉真的很糟。他在那里是人类。他完全是人类。这让你觉得上帝离我们并不远。他就那里。
If the cross had been smaller, I probably wouldn't have stopped. And I mean, not like five feet smaller. I mean, it's still huge. It's 195 feet. But if it was the size of these little ones, I probably wouldn't have taken the time to stop, just because I want to get home, you know? I've been driving. I've been on the road for three days now.
如果十字架小一点，我可能就不会停下来了。我是说，不是小五英尺那种。我是说，它依然巨大。它有195英尺。但如果它只有这些小雕像那么大，我可能不会花时间停下来，仅仅是因为我想回家，你知道吗？我一直在开车。我已经上路三天了。
When Steve first erected the cross, he didn't put in benches or statues or anything. It didn't occur to him that people might want to stop. He only thought of it as a giant billboard. But people did stop. And over time, it became clear that the people who stopped wanted something more. They wanted to pray. They wanted to talk. Often, they wanted help. Steve and his family found themselves staying at the cross, ministering to people in need. There's now a staff of 14 on hand to counsel people and pray with them almost 24 hours a day.
史蒂夫最初竖起十字架时，并没有设置长椅、雕像或任何东西。他没想过人们可能想停下来。他只把它视为一个巨大的广告牌。但人们确实停下来了。随着时间的推移，很明显，停下来的人想要更多。他们想祈祷。他们想交谈。他们通常需要帮助。史蒂夫和他的家人发现自己一直待在十字架旁，侍奉有需要的人。现在有14名工作人员在场，几乎24小时为人们提供咨询和祈祷。
It's our last night at the cross, close to midnight. Floodlights on the huge wood structure surrounded by deep black in all directions. We watch a truck pull in. The driver comes down from his rig and approaches a counselor named Les [? Weatherling. ?]
这是我们在十字架旁的最后一晚，接近午夜。巨大的木质结构上的泛光灯被周围深沉的黑暗所包围。我们看着一辆卡车驶入。司机从他的驾驶室下来，走向一位名叫莱斯（音译）的辅导员。
Yes, sir?
是的，先生？
Excuse me. May I borrow your phone?
打扰一下。我可以借用你的电话吗？
The driver, whose name is Eric, says he wants to borrow the phone so he can pray with his wife, who's sick back home in Oklahoma. He doesn't reach her, so Les offers to pray with him.
司机，名叫埃里克，说他想借电话，这样他可以和在俄克拉荷马家乡生病的妻子一起祈祷。他没有联系上她，所以莱斯主动提出和他一起祈祷。
They walk up to the crucifixion scene. It's set off to the side, at the top of the set of white amphitheater steps. They kneel and hold hands, and when Eric begins to pray, it's in the mix of English and Kiowa. He's a Kiowa Comanche Indian and an Evangelical Christian.
他们走向钉十字架的场景。它位于白色露天剧场台阶顶部的一侧。他们跪下并握住双手，当埃里克开始祈祷时，那是英语和基奥瓦语的混合。他是基奥瓦科曼奇印第安人，也是福音派基督徒。
[SPEAKING KIOWA] Heavenly Father, we come to you. [UNINTELLIGIBLE] burden to my heart. Watch over my wife. [SPEAKING KIOWA] I have no-- whatever I have, please give it to her. Heavenly Father--
[讲基奥瓦语]天父，我们来到你面前。[听不清]我心中的重担。看顾我的妻子。[讲基奥瓦语]我没有——无论我有什么，请给她。天父——
It's dark and lonely, and Eric is the only visitor at the cross. When he's done praying, he tells us that he's stopped here maybe 150 times on his truck route.
天黑且寂寞，埃里克是十字架旁唯一的访客。当他祈祷结束后，他告诉我们，他在他的卡车路线上可能已经在那里停过150次了。
Tonight, the reason why I stopped is my wife's liver and kidney's not functioning like it should. And they don't know if they're going to go in tomorrow morning, need surgery or not.
今晚，我停下来的原因是妻子的肝脏和肾脏功能不正常。他们不知道明天早上是否需要手术。
You know, if everything's going real smooth, then the last thing you want to thing about's eternity. And when the suffering's coming your way, you stop and think about, well, maybe there's more to it than this world. So it's these suffering events a lot of times that turns us around.
你知道，如果一切都很顺利，那么你最后想到的就是永恒。而当苦难降临到你身上时，你会停下来思考，好吧，也许这个世界之外还有更多东西。所以这些苦难事件很多时候会让我们转变。
When you first meet the guy who built the cross, Steve Thomas doesn't seem like the type that would understand suffering, with his picture-perfect family. He's been married to his wife Bobby for 31 years. His son Zach is an All-Pro linebacker for the Miami Dolphins. And his daughter Katina, who recently married one of her brother's teammates, is a former Miss Amarillo who won the Miss Texas swimsuit competition in 1997.
当你第一次见到那个建造十字架的人时，史蒂夫·托马斯看起来不像那种会理解苦难的人，因为他的家庭像画一样完美。他与妻子鲍比结婚31年了。他的儿子扎克是迈阿密海豚队的全明星线卫。他的女儿卡蒂娜最近嫁给了她哥哥的一位队友，是前阿马里洛小姐，曾在1997年赢得得克萨斯小姐泳装比赛。
But Steve's current family is very different from the one he grew up in. His parents were both alcoholics, and his dad was sometimes violent. This violence erupted one night when Steve was kid. There had been clues that something was coming.
但史蒂夫现在的家庭与他成长的那个家庭截然不同。他的父母都是酒鬼，他的父亲有时有暴力倾向。这种暴力在史蒂夫还是个孩子的一个晚上爆发了。有一些迹象表明有什么事情要发生。
You know, he'd been reading the Bible every night. And my dad didn't go to church. We'd get up about 7:00, he'd been up since 5:00 reading the Bible, so we knew something was going on, but we didn't know what.
你知道，他每天晚上都在读圣经。我爸爸不去教堂。我们7点左右起床，他从5点开始就一直在读圣经，所以我们知道发生了什么，但我们不知道是什么。
Would you be willing to tell me just what happened the night that your dad--
你愿意告诉我你爸爸那天晚上到底发生了什么吗——
Well, he took a claw hammer after my sisters and my mother, and then came upstairs after us brothers, and by the time we'd heard all the commotion, we were awake. And my mother had to have a plate. Both my sisters had brain surgery, and my mother had brain surgery, and she had to have a plate inserted in her head.
嗯，他拿出一把羊角锤追打我的姐妹和母亲，然后上楼追我们兄弟，当我们听到所有骚动时，我们已经醒了。我母亲不得不安装一块钢板。两个姐妹都做了脑部手术，我母亲做了脑部手术，她不得不往头里植入一块钢板。
How old were you?
你当时多大？
I was 17. I was the oldest of five. So we ranged from 10 to 17.
我17岁。我是五个孩子中的老大。所以我们从10岁到17岁不等。
None of the kids died?
没有孩子死亡吗？
No, nobody died. But my sisters, they really were not the same. They've had some trouble, mainly in their school and schooling and stuff with their grades. They didn't have the grades that us brothers did. And I think it's because of injuries they had from that incident.
没有，没人死亡。但我的姐妹们，她们真的不一样了。她们遇到了一些麻烦，主要是学校和学习成绩之类的。她们没有我们兄弟那样的成绩。我认为这是因为那次事件给她们带来的伤害。
And the incident ended that night how?
那次事件那天晚上是怎么结束的？
Well, my dad shot himself, and he lived about 12 more days, and then died.
嗯，我爸爸自杀了，他多活了大约12天，然后去世了。
Steve Thomas believes he was chosen by God to build the cross. Quite literally, he believes he was selected, perhaps even intentionally molded with the traumas of his childhood, which didn't end with his father's death. 10 years later, his mother killed herself, too.
史蒂夫·托马斯相信他被上帝选中建造这个十字架。从字面上讲，他相信他是被挑选出来的，甚至可能是有意用他童年的创伤塑造的，这些创伤并没有随着他父亲的去世而结束。10年后，他的母亲也自杀了。
You see all these people driving down the Interstate. The ones that drive by-- you probably have them in every lane-- hunky dory, everything's running real good in their lives. They've probably got plenty of money. Everybody's healthy. And they look at the cross and say, huh! Not bad. And then they think about getting to the beach in California, you know?
你看到所有这些人在州际公路上开车。那些开车经过的——你可能在每条车道上都有他们——一切都好，他们生活中的一切都很顺利。他们可能有足够的钱。每个人都很健康。他们看着十字架说，哈！不错。然后他们想到去加州的海滩，你知道吗？
But then you get the people coming down the Interstate that are trying to find out where they're going to get their next dollar, and their wife is suffering from cancer, maybe one of their sons is into drugs. And they're driving along, and they just whip in here. They don't know why. Like I say, we ask them why, and they say, I don't know, I just came. And that's because they're searching for something to change that. They want suffering to go away.
但随后你就会遇到沿着州际公路行驶的人，他们试图找出下一美元从哪里来，他们的妻子患有癌症，也许他们的一个儿子在吸毒。他们开车经过，只是猛地拐了进来。他们不知道为什么。就像我说的，我们问他们为什么，他们说，我不知道，我只是来了。那是因为他们正在寻找改变这一切的东西。他们想让苦难消失。
When he first built the cross, Steve thought of it as kind an advertisement for Jesus. He didn't realize that it was really a massive beacon calling out to the suffering and promising relief. He started out wanting a billboard, but what he ended up with was kind of a church.
史蒂夫最初建造十字架时，把它视为耶稣的一种广告。他没意识到它实际上是一个巨大的灯塔，呼唤着苦难并承诺缓解。他开始想要一个广告牌，但最后他得到的是一种教堂。
Josh Noel, here in Chicago.
乔什·诺埃尔，在芝加哥。
[MUSIC - "JESUS WAS A CROSS MAKER" BY CASS ELLIOT]
[音乐 - 卡斯·艾略特演唱的《耶稣是十字架制造者》]
Coming up, factory workers at the epiphany plant, in a minute, from Public Radio International and Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，顿悟工厂的工厂工人们，稍后，来自国际公共广播电台和芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, during this Christmas season, Faith, people acting on their faith, people stuck in their faith, for better or for worse.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，为你带来关于那个主题的各种不同类型的故事。今天的节目，在这个圣诞季，主题是信仰，人们践行他们的信仰，人们困在他们的信仰中，无论好坏。
We've arrived at Act three of our program. Act Three, The Epiphany Biz. Bill Lychak tells this story of faith when it is held by other people.
我们已经到达节目的第三幕。第三幕，顿悟生意。比尔·利查克讲述了这个关于信仰被他人持有时发生的故事。
And so the Lord says, go to Peoria. Give away all you possess and go to Peoria. He says, if you desire to do my will, if you truly want to be my servants, go to Peoria. He says, I have a place for you there.
所以主说，去皮奥里亚。放弃你拥有的一切，去皮奥里亚。他说，如果你渴望遵行我的旨意，如果你真的想成为我的仆人，就去皮奥里亚。他说，我在那里为你准备了一个地方。
And so, what do you do? I suppose if the Word really comes and comes clear enough, you don't have much of a choice. You have to listen and do what God tells you. You have to divest yourself of every single thing you own, break the news to your friends and your family, your mother-in-law, neighbors, turn off the gas and electric, stop the mail, quit your jobs, pull the kids out of school, pack up a van, and leave everything and everyone you know, and head off to Peoria.
那么，你会怎么做？我想，如果神的话真的来了，而且来得足够清晰，你就没有太多选择。你必须倾听并做上帝告诉你的事。你必须放弃你拥有的每一件东西，告诉你的朋友和家人、你的岳母、邻居这个消息，关掉煤气和电力，停止接收邮件，辞掉工作，让孩子们退学，收拾一辆面包车，离开你认识的一切和所有人，前往皮奥里亚。
You drive all day and night and reach, at long last, the outskirts of town. You cross the town line and pull off by the side of the highway, the fields lying flat and covered with dirty snow. And you wait and pray, pray and wait.
你开车整天整夜，终于到达了城镇郊区。你穿过城镇界限，在高速公路旁停下，田野平坦，覆盖着肮脏的雪。你等待并祈祷，祈祷并等待。
I spent all morning on the phone with a man who did this, gave away everything and led his family to Peoria, sat at the outskirts of town as the light faded, his wife and kids shivering in the cold, the trucks and cars rushing past. God had only directed him as far as Peoria, which is why they waited for the next directive at the town line.
我整个上午都在和一个人通电话，他就是这样做的，放弃了一切，带领他的家人去了皮奥里亚，在城镇郊区坐着，天色渐暗，他的妻子和孩子们在寒冷中发抖，卡车和汽车飞驰而过。上帝只指引他到了皮奥里亚，这就是为什么他们在城镇界限等待下一个指令。
And yes, it all sounds completely crazy to him, too, he says, which makes me like him. He knows that this is beyond reason. He knows that it's a thing no one could understand, the fact that he and his wife both received word from God like this, and that God would be so specific, and that they would actually do it, give away everything and follow this voice to Illinois.
是的，这一切听起来对他来说也完全疯狂，他说，这让我喜欢他。他知道这超出了理性。他知道这是没人能理解的事情，事实上他和他的妻子都收到了上帝这样的旨意，上帝会如此具体，他们真的会那样做，放弃一切并跟随这个声音来到伊利诺伊州。
The story was sent to Guideposts, a religious-minded monthly where my job is to rewrite these true stories of hope and inspiration. It's not sold on newsstands, but the magazine has more than three million subscribers. For more than 50 years, the magazine has been rolling out its brand of Good News to the world, first-person accounts taken from actual events that are testaments to faith of some sort. As the magazine's mission statement says, "Our articles present tested methods for developing courage, strength, and positive attitudes through faith in God."
这个故事被寄到了《向导》，一本具有宗教思想的月刊，我的工作是重写这些关于希望和灵感的真实故事。它不在报刊亭出售，但该杂志拥有超过三百万订户。50多年来，该杂志一直在向世界推出其“好消息”品牌，取自实际事件的第一人称叙述，是对某种信仰的证明。正如该杂志的使命宣言所说，“我们的文章提供了经过验证的方法，通过对上帝的信仰来发展勇气、力量和积极的态度。”
My job is to make sure that the story becomes a Guideposts story, make sure that it conforms to the expectations of our readers. The story needs to have its all-walks-of-life beginning, its crisis or test of faith, its dark night of the soul, and its triumph of spirit, its turnaround. God's goodness, whatever that means, must shine through somewhere, some way, somehow.
我的工作是确保这个故事成为一个《向导》故事，确保它符合我们读者的期望。这个故事需要有各行各业的开头、危机或信仰考验、灵魂的黑暗之夜、精神的胜利、转折。上帝的善良，无论这意味着什么，必须在某处、某种方式、某种程度上闪耀出来。
In-house, we call this God factor in the story its cello, like the instrument. And when line edits come back to us, we get directives like "more cello," or "less cello," or "where's the cello?" Everything is in the service of the cello, and the cello sets up the story's payoff. Everything works out. They find their home in Peoria. Or even better, they find their home wherever God wants them to be.
在内部，我们将故事中的这种上帝因素称为“大提琴”，就像那种乐器。当编辑修改意见传回给我们时，我们会得到指令，比如“多一点大提琴”、“少一点大提琴”或“大提琴在哪儿？”一切都是为了服务大提琴，而大提琴为故事的结局做了铺垫。一切都会好起来的。他们在皮奥里亚找到了家。或者更好的是，他们在上帝希望他们所在的任何地方找到了家。
The stories run the gamut. A guy rescues manatees in Florida. A crop duster, or beekeeper, or fisherman survives some great accident, or addiction, or loss. Someone finds an unopened letter from World War II and forwards it to the widow. A man goes to Peoria. The variations are endless for us line workers at the epiphany plant.
故事五花八门。一个人在佛罗里达营救海牛。一个农药喷洒员，或养蜂人，或渔夫在某种重大事故、上瘾或损失中幸存下来。有人找到一封二战时期未拆封的信并将其转交给遗孀。一个人去了皮奥里亚。对于我们这些顿悟工厂的流水线工人来说，变化是无穷无尽的。
In the epiphany business, each epiphanic moment is called the takeaway, and takeaways need to be short, sweet, and positive. Variations of the "I trusted in God, and that has made all the difference" theme. Amen.
在顿悟生意中，每一个顿悟时刻被称为“外卖”，而“外卖”需要短小、甜美且积极。“我信靠上帝，这带来了所有的不同”主题的变体。阿门。
Most of my days at work are filled with people who talk to God. Help this, rescue these, give us that, thank you for those. What made the Peoria story so fascinating was that God not only spoke back to these people, but that he got back to them in such a specific, puckish way.
我在工作中的大多数日子都充满了与上帝交谈的人。帮助这个，拯救那些，给我们那个，感谢你做的一切。让皮奥里亚的故事如此迷人的是，上帝不仅回应了这些人，而且他以如此具体、顽皮的方式回应了他们。
I love the image of them on the side of that highway, wondering what to do next. They're all cold and hungry and scared and disheartened and dispirited. And in the dark, they drive to that first cheap motel they see. The five of them stay until they're down to their last $12. Again, their prayers are answered, and they find a church. They place their last dollar in the collection plate and find a home that same day. And so on.
我喜欢他们在那条高速公路旁的样子，想知道下一步该做什么。他们又冷又饿、害怕、灰心丧气、垂头丧气。在黑暗中，他们开车前往他们看到的第一个便宜汽车旅馆。他们五个人一直待到只剩下12美元。同样，他们的祈祷得到了回应，他们找到了一个教堂。他们把最后的一美元放入奉献盘，并在同一天找到了家。等等。
It's a crazy, miracle-laden story which barely makes sense, really. Yet talking to this man, he isn't the unquestioning fanatic that I had imagined. In fact, by the middle of our conversation, I'm convinced that something extraordinary has happened to him. I'm convinced that, in his own way, he heard the voice of God. And I'm convinced he made a cold sweat leap of faith, and that he had doubts, and that he has a deeper faith now because of this test.
这是一个疯狂、充满神迹的故事，说实话，几乎说不通。然而与这个人交谈时，他并不是我所想象的那种盲目的狂热分子。事实上，在谈话到一半时，我确信他身上发生了一些非凡的事情。我确信，以他自己的方式，他听到了上帝的声音。我确信他进行了一次冷汗淋漓的信仰飞跃，他有过怀疑，而且因为这次考验，他现在有了更深层的信仰。
I punch out that night with a glimmer of what it's like when what you believe and what you do are actually one and the same thing. And when I get the story back for revision the next morning, my editor has written over my cello-filled takeaway in big, block letters, "Preach it, Brother Billy. Preach it!"
那天晚上，我带着一丝光亮下班，当你的信仰和你所做的事情实际上是一回事时，那是怎样的感觉。第二天早上，当我拿到故事进行修改时，我的编辑在我的大提琴式“外卖”上用大块字母写道：“传道吧，比尔兄弟。传道吧！”
I feel like a whistleblower telling you this, these inner workings of the ghostwriter, the anonymous content provider, the humble commodifier of insight and faith. The sad truth is that I spend a couple of days on the Peoria story, and it's gone, and the next thing is on my desk, roughly one story per week. Next week is Wedding Lady. The week after is Iwo Jima guy.
我感觉自己像个告密者在告诉你这些，代笔者、匿名内容提供者、洞察力和信仰的卑微商品化者的内心运作。可悲的事实是，我在皮奥里亚的故事上花了两天时间，它就过去了，下一件事就在我的办公桌上，大约每周一个故事。下周是“婚礼女士”。接下来的一周是“硫磺岛家伙”。
Yet still, there are worse ways to make a living. In fact, it's a surprisingly pleasant kind of work, even for the more secular clock-punchers among us.
尽管如此，还有更糟糕的谋生方式。事实上，这是一种出奇令人愉快的工作，即使是对我们这些更世俗的打卡上班族来说。
The fact is, I hear commands as well, vague and small-voiced. And I believe everyone I know hears them. What, really, is the difference between "go to Peoria" and "make the film" or "write the book" or "marry the girl" or any of the countless passions that guide our days? These are all things my friends expend great amounts of energy working for and dreaming about. And they're all acts of faith in one way or another, all the urges that carry us through our lives and give us meaning and help us make sense of the accidents that befall us.
事实是，我也听到了指令，模糊且低声。我相信我认识的每个人都听到了。说实话，“去皮奥里亚”和“拍电影”或“写书”或“娶那个女孩”或引导我们度过每一天的无数激情之间有什么区别？这些都是我的朋友花费大量精力追求和梦想的事情。而且它们在某种程度上都是信仰的行为，所有那些载着我们度过生命、赋予我们意义并帮助我们理解降临在我们身上的意外的冲动。
And here comes the cello, when I think of it this way, when I think how we have to admit that the best in us is utterly mad, or starts out utterly mad. A dim voice urging us on to our own kinds of Peoria.
这就是大提琴出现的地方，当我这样想时，当我想到我们必须承认我们身上最好的一面是完全疯狂的，或者一开始是完全疯狂的。一个微弱的声音敦促我们走向我们自己种类的皮奥里亚。
Bill Lychak lives in New York. His story first appeared on the website openletters.net.
比尔·利查克住在纽约。他的故事首次出现在网站openletters.net上。
[MUSIC - "THE BIBLE TELLS ME SO" BY THE JOHN MATTHEWS FAMILY]
[音乐 - 约翰·马修斯家庭演唱的《圣经告诉我》]
Act Four, First Be Reconciled To Thy Brother, and Then Come and Offer Thy Gift.
第四幕，先与你的弟兄和好，然后来献你的礼物。
The problem with faith is that often the faithful do not necessarily agree with each other about how to worship God. Susie Putz-Drury tells the story of some people in that situation at a church in Tennessee.
信仰的问题在于，信徒们往往并不一定就如何崇拜上帝达成一致。苏西·普茨-德鲁里讲述了在田纳西州一个教堂里处于那种境地的人们的故事。
When Bethel Presbyterian Church got a white minister, they started to worship differently.
当伯特利长老会教堂聘请了一位白人牧师时，他们开始以不同的方式崇拜。
Lucy Cox has been going to Bethel her entire life, ever since she was an orphan and the church took her in. When she was younger, Bethel was a place where you went to hear the gospel, to sing and rejoice and be moved by the Lord, moved almost physically, not just in your head.
露西·考克斯一生都在去伯特利，自从她还是孤儿，教会收留她以来。当她年轻时，伯特利是一个你去听福音、唱歌、欢呼并被主感动的地方，被物理上感动，不仅仅是在你的脑子里。
I used to sing top of my voice, because when that spirit really hits, I'm not Lucy. But now I do it my pastor's way, nice and quiet, when I'm here. But when I'm not here, I do it God's way.
我过去常常用尽全力唱歌，因为当那种精神真正袭来时，我就不是露西了。但现在我用我牧师的方式，安静地，当我在那里时。但当我不在那里时，我用上帝的方式。
On some Sundays after services at Bethel, about half of the people from the congregation get in their cars and drive to another church, where they can sing the way Lucy Cox likes. They've been doing this for 15 years.
在伯特利教堂礼拜结束后的某些周日，大约一半的会众开车前往另一个教堂，在那里他们可以以露西·考克斯喜欢的方式唱歌。他们这样做了15年。
A little background. In 1985, the Presbyterian church in Tennessee hired a young preacher to serve several churches in Dandridge, Tennessee. The minister they hired, Ralph Hutchison, is a slight, earnest, red-headed guy. Of the four churches Ralph was called to serve, three of them had entirely white congregations. The other church was Lucy's church, Bethel, whose congregation is entirely black.
一点背景。1985年，田纳西州的长老会聘请了一位年轻的传教士来服务田纳西州丹德里奇的几座教堂。他们聘请的牧师拉尔夫·哈奇森，是一个瘦小、诚恳、红头发的家伙。在拉尔夫被召去服务的四座教堂中，其中三座拥有完全白人的会众。另一座教堂是露西的教堂，伯特利，它的会众完全是黑人。
And for about five years, this arrangement with the four churches worked out pretty well, with Ralph dividing his time among the four churches, preaching at each twice a month. Ralph was also getting to be sort of an activist during this time. He preached about the evils of racism and other social justice issues, and he got involved with a group in Knoxville that was protesting some of the US government's policies in Central America. The group was trying to show that the US government was causing the deaths of innocent people in the region, and Ralph ended up with a leading role.
在大约五年时间里，这四座教堂的安排运作得相当好，拉尔夫将时间分配在四座教堂之间，每月在每座教堂传道两次。拉尔夫在这段时间里也开始成为某种积极分子。他宣扬种族主义和其他社会正义问题的邪恶，并加入了一个在诺克斯维尔的团体，抗议美国政府在拉丁美洲的一些政策。该团体试图证明美国政府正在导致该地区无辜人民的死亡，拉尔夫最终扮演了主角。
We held a mock funeral designed to get publicity, and it did. The TV cameras were there. We carried a casket down Market Square. And I was in the front of the procession in my clergy robe. And so it was on TV.
我们举行了一场旨在宣传的模拟葬礼，而且成功了。电视摄像机都在那里。我们抬着棺材沿着市场广场走。我穿着神职长袍走在游行队伍的最前面。所以它上了电视。
And a couple weeks later, I get a visit from the patriarch of the church, came in and sat down in the office. And basically what he told me was that he completely supported me politically. He thought what I was doing was right, the policies of the government were wrong, no problem there. So I was kind of nodding. And he said, but people in the congregation are really uncomfortable when their neighbors ask them why they saw their preacher on TV.
几周后，我收到了教堂族长的访问，他进来坐在办公室里。他基本上告诉我的是，他在政治上完全支持我。他认为我做的是对的，政府的政策是错的，这没问题。所以我点点头。他说，但会众在邻居问他们为什么在电视上看到他们的传教士时，感到非常不舒服。
Ralph and his co-pastor found themselves being cast out of three white churches they had been called to serve. In the end, the only church Ralph had left was the black church, Bethel.
拉尔夫和他的共同牧师发现自己被他们服务的三座白人教堂赶了出来。最后，拉尔夫剩下的唯一教堂是黑人教堂，伯特利。
We were crushed!
我们崩溃了！
This is Roberta Robinson, who's been a member of Bethel since she was an infant, and is a church elder, like a deacon. She says the congregation couldn't believe what the white churches did.
这是罗伯塔·罗宾逊，她从婴儿时期就是伯特利的成员，也是教堂长老，像执事一样。她说会众无法相信白人教堂所做的事情。
And it was was one of their own. That's one thing we just couldn't imagine in a human, one human being treating another like that, especially Christian believers. I really felt for both Ralph and Dale. They were really just getting a little taste of what we as a people went through. It was in a different form, but really it was the same thing. That's how we got stuck with him.
而且那是他们自己人。那是我们无法想象的事情，一个人那样对待另一个人，特别是基督徒信徒。我真的为拉尔夫和戴尔感到难过。他们真的只是稍微尝到了我们作为一个人群所经历的东西。它以不同的形式出现，但本质上是一样的。这就是我们为什么被他困住的原因。
It did take some time, though, for both Ralph and the members of his congregation to get used to each other. Ralph is more liberal than they are, certainly on social issues. His regular full-time job is as an activist against nuclear weapons. And the first time I went to one of his services, it was years ago, but I still remember being shocked to hear him refer to God, in passing, as a she. Ralph also preaches about things like gay rights, and he says when he does preach on God's blessing of gay people and their love for one another, some in the congregation, the men in particular, just sit in the pews and sort of shake their heads. Here's Roberta again.
不过，拉尔夫和他的会众成员确实花了一些时间才习惯彼此。拉尔夫比他们更自由，特别是在社会问题上。他全职工作是作为反对核武器的积极分子。第一次我去参加他的礼拜时，那是几年前了，但我仍然记得听到他顺便将上帝称为“她”时的震惊。拉尔夫还宣扬同性恋权利之类的事情，他说当他真的宣扬上帝对同性恋者及其相互之爱的祝福时，会众中的一些人，特别是男人们，只是坐在长椅上，摇着头。这是罗伯塔。
Well, I can remember I went to his-- well, I'll call it a trial sermon. And he was preaching, and I thought, What on earth is he talking about?
嗯，我记得我去参加他的——好吧，我称之为试验布道。他当时正在布道，我想，他到底在说什么？
Here's Ralph.
这是拉尔夫。
The congregation was responsive. During preaching, they talk back to you. That was not an experience that I'd had before.
会众反应热烈。在布道期间，他们会回话给你。那不是我以前有过的经历。
This is Sue Pruitt, who stayed a member of Bethel even after she moved 30 miles away.
这是苏·普鲁特，即使在她搬到30英里外后，她仍然是伯特利的成员。
It was real funny when he first came here. You know, we do a lot of singing. And he sung good, but I guess kind of like a white person. He sings so hard now, you can see the veins in his neck. Puts a little movement to it, and a little beat to it. So now he hangs in there.
他刚来这里时真的很滑稽。你知道，我们唱很多歌。他唱得不错，但我猜有点像白人。他现在唱得那么卖力，你可以看到他脖子上的静脉。带着一点动作，一点节拍。所以现在他坚持住了。
Gradually, though, they began to settle into one another. Ralph got married and had kids, and the congregation was thrilled about that. They had potlucks and Sunday services and Martin Luther King dinners. They even worked together to start an anti-discrimination organization in the county.
不过，渐渐地，他们开始互相安定下来。拉尔夫结婚并有了孩子，会众对此感到非常兴奋。他们举行了聚餐、周日礼拜和马丁·路德·金晚宴。他们甚至一起工作，在县里创办了一个反歧视组织。
But even though they're getting along great, there's still one thing that sort of separates them. Ralph has changed the way they practice their own faith in their own church. And it's here that the members of Bethel Church, and Ralph too, see race playing a role. This is Calvin Ballinger, the church patriarch.
但尽管他们相处得很好，仍然有一件事将他们分开。拉尔夫改变了他们在他自己的教堂里实践自己信仰的方式。正是在这里，伯特利教堂的成员，还有拉尔夫，看到了种族在起作用。这是教堂族长卡尔文·巴林杰。
The black preaching style has a charisma, you would say. There's times I like to get, all you say, the emotion of the gospel of the black churches. If it is emotion, he's hiding it. That's why I say, [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE] emotion, I don't know if he ever will have emotion or not. Emotion is good. That's good for the soul, you know? It means he's been touched.
黑人的布道风格有一种魅力，你会这么说。有几次我喜欢得到，你们说的，黑人教堂福音的情感。如果那是情感，他把它藏起来了。这就是为什么我说，[听不清短语]情感，我不知道他是否会有情感。情感是好的。那对灵魂有好处，你知道吗？这意味着他被触动了。
Lucy Cox likes Ralph. She's close to him, gets a lot from him. But she says he doesn't bring her the main things she wants from her minister.
露西·考克斯喜欢拉尔夫。她和他很亲近，从他那里得到了很多。但她说他没有给她带来她想从牧师那里得到的主要东西。
I think, for me, his role as a minister heat me hot with the Word of God, bring me the Word. If I can't stand it, then pull my shoes off.
我认为，对我来说，他作为牧师的角色是用上帝的话语让我热起来，给我带来话语。如果我受不了，那就把我的鞋子脱掉。
Ralph's sermons aren't designed to heat anyone hot with the Word of God. He's not a big shouter. He's cerebral. He writes out his sermons beforehand and then recites them word-for-word at Sunday service. He sounds a lot like Garrison Keillor at the pulpit, without the jokes. He makes up stories about fictional characters to raise whatever issue he's trying to get people to think about.
拉尔夫的布道不是为了让任何人用上帝的话语变得火热。他不是个大声疾呼的人。他是理性的。他在周日礼拜前写好布道词，然后逐字逐句地背诵出来。他在讲坛上听起来很像加里森·基勒，只是没有笑话。他编造关于虚构人物的故事，来提出他试图让人们思考的任何议题。
Last Tuesday, Marty Bryson made his way down the hallway to the fourth door on the left. He knocked softly and he heard Evelyn Morrison's voice say, "Come in." When she saw a Marty, she smiled. "My most faithful visitor," she said.
上周二，马蒂·布赖森沿着走廊走到左边的第四扇门。他轻轻敲了敲门，听到伊芙琳·莫里森的声音说，“进来”。当她看到马蒂时，她笑了。“我最忠实的访客，”她说。
I'm sure a quick excerpt on the radio just sounds corny. It's hard to express, really, why this sermon was so riveting, but it really was, and not just for me. He had us all. It was kind of like a spell being broken when he said "amen," signaling the end of the sermon. People came back from the world he had sent us to, finding the page for the next hymn, shifting in their seats, getting ready for the offering.
我肯定广播里的一个简短摘录听起来很陈词滥调。很难表达为什么这个布道如此扣人心弦，但它确实是，不仅仅是对我。他抓住了我们所有人。当他说“阿门”标志着布道结束时，就像咒语被打破了一样。人们从他派遣我们去的世界回来，寻找下一首赞美诗的页面，在座位上挪动，准备奉献。
Everyone tells me this is something they like about Ralph. They like that he's smart, and they like to hear how he interprets the Bible. And the stuff they don't like, they kind of shrug off, except when it comes to heating them hot with the Word of God.
每个人都告诉我这是他们喜欢拉尔夫的一点。他们喜欢他聪明，喜欢听他如何解释圣经。他们不喜欢的东西，他们只是耸耸肩，除非涉及到用上帝的话语让他们变得火热。
When Ralph first started at Bethel, one of the elders took him aside and tried to show him how to preach in a more dynamic way. Ralph says it just felt wrong.
当拉尔夫刚开始在伯特利时，一位长老把他拉到一边，试图向他展示如何以更有活力的方式布道。拉尔夫说那感觉就是不对。
I mean, I can mimic an Evangelical preacher, whether they're white or black. So I know what sort of the rhetorical patterns are of that kind of preaching. They're not particularly authentic to me, and wouldn't it seem weird to them if I stood up and preached a sermon using the cadences and the rhetorical devices of Martin Luther King Jr., except I'm this little white guy, right? And so they would think, what's with that? You know?
我是说，我可以模仿一位福音派传教士，无论他们是白人还是黑人。所以我知道那种布道的修辞模式是什么样的。对我来说，它们并不是特别真实，如果我站起来，用马丁·路德·金博士的节奏和修辞技巧来布道，我不觉得很奇怪吗？但我这个小白人，对吧？所以他们会想，那是什么？你知道吗？
For a lot of people, the emotional side of spirituality is the safe and the easy side, and they like to go there because it feels good. So you go there week after week. You go on Sunday. You get that pick-me-up. And it might last until Wednesday. And I think, more so now than I used to, I think that there is great value in having your life enriched by emotional spirituality and those experiences.
对很多人来说，灵性的情感方面是安全且容易的一面，他们喜欢去那里，因为感觉很好。所以你周复一周地去。你周日去。你得到了那种提神。它可能持续到周三。我认为，比我过去认为的更多，我认为情感灵性带来的生命丰富和那些经验有很大的价值。
However, if that's all your religion is to you, then your religion is failing you in a great way.
然而，如果你的宗教对你来说仅此而已，那么你的宗教在很大程度上正在让你失望。
[FIERY SERMON]
[热情的布道]
It's a Sunday afternoon, about an hour after the Bethel service ended, and many of the congregants are at the all-black AME Zion Church, a few miles outside of town. When I get there, I see Roberta and Sue and Calvin and others who regularly go to Bethel. It's hard to believe that some of these folks are the same people. At Bethel, they sit pretty quietly during the service. Here they're bursting out with joy, so happy, completely happy, and unrestrained.
那是一个周日下午，伯特利礼拜结束大约一小时后，许多会众都在镇外几英里的全黑人AME锡安教堂。当我到达那里时，我看到罗伯塔、苏和卡尔文以及其他经常去伯特利的人。很难相信其中一些人是同一个人。在伯特利，他们在礼拜期间坐得相当安静。在这里，他们充满喜悦，如此快乐，完全快乐且不受约束。
The big difference between Ralph and his congregation is over more than style. What several members patiently explained to me more than a few times is that the style means something. It gets to basic differences in how you feel God, how present and alive He is for you in church, in music, in your daily life.
拉尔夫和他的会众之间最大的区别不仅仅在于风格。几位成员耐心地向我解释不止几次，风格意味着某种东西。它触及了你如何感受上帝的基本差异，他在教堂、音乐、日常生活中为你展现得多么真实和活着。
And this leads to different answers to the question of what people want to get out of church, or out of any worship experience.
这导致了对人们想从教堂，或从任何崇拜经历中得到什么的答案不同。
[GOSPEL SINGING]
[福音演唱]
We as a black people, our religion, or their religion-- I'm referring to my great-grandparents and all-- that was really all they had to rely on, was their faith. And they would get so emotional just thinking about, well, I'm being mistreated here on earth, but I know that I've got something to look forward to. And they would really, really get emotional about it. And you have to be black, I'm telling you, just have to be black, to understand that.
我们作为黑人，我们的宗教，或者他们的宗教——我指的是我的曾祖父母和所有人——那真的是他们唯一能依靠的东西，就是他们的信仰。他们会因为想到，嗯，我在地球上受到虐待，但我知道我还有东西可以期待而变得如此激动。他们真的会为此变得非常激动。而且你必须是黑人，我告诉你，你必须是黑人，才能理解这一点。
You'll hear him say, well, just hold on. No matter how life is here, there's a better life. Just hold on. Now, you will hear that elsewhere. Other churches, yes. But you're not going to hear that spoke and mentioned in the Presbyterian church. So yes, there's a lot of difference, I feel.
你会听到他说，嗯，坚持住。无论生活在这里怎么样，还有一个更好的生活。坚持住。现在，你会听到其他地方提到。其他教堂，是的。但你不会在长老会教堂听到那种说法和提及。所以是的，我感觉有很多不同。
Instead of talking about the afterlife, Ralph focuses on other things.
拉尔夫不谈论来世，而是专注于其他事情。
Oh, he encourages this, you know-- He knows that there's injustice, and that we should, as a people, although we've suffered injustice, that we should work toward justice. Now, he stresses that an awful lot. Try to straighten out the world we're in. But I don't hear him-- I can't remember hearing him speak of the next world, not that much, not that much.
噢，他鼓励这一点，你知道——他知道有不公正，而且我们作为一个民族，尽管我们遭受了不公正，我们也应该为正义而努力。现在，他非常强调这一点。尽量理顺我们所处的世界。但我没听过他——我不记得听过他谈论下一个世界，没那么多，没那么多。
It's not my job to save souls. Sometimes people think that should be my job, too, in my congregation. That's OK. But I think the Bible's very clear that salvation is a this-world promise.
拯救灵魂不是我的工作。有时人们认为那也应该是我的工作，在我的会众里。那没关系。但我认为圣经非常清楚，救赎是一个此世的应许。
It's not that Ralph doesn't understand what Roberta is talking about. Ralph actually grew up in a Pentecostal church in rural Pennsylvania, a church that was all about the afterlife and stirring up emotions to a fever pitch, on schedule, every Sunday.
并不是拉尔夫不明白罗伯塔在说什么。拉尔夫实际上是在宾夕法尼亚州农村的一个五旬节派教堂长大的，那个教堂完全关于来世，并每周按计划将情绪激起至狂热。
And many times, in our case, that emotional pitch was one in which the primary emotion was fear. You were to be afraid of God, who was angry with you because you sinned. You knew you sinned, didn't you? Well, yeah. We knew we did. And God was going to get you. And so there's hellfire, there's brimstone, there's eternal damnation.
而且很多时候，在我们的情况下，那种情绪的高涨主要的情绪是恐惧。你要敬畏上帝，他对你很生气，因为你犯罪了。你知道你犯罪了，不是吗？嗯，是的。我们知道我们做了。而且上帝会来抓你。所以有地狱之火，有硫磺，有永恒的诅咒。
I think as far as they were aware, the sum total of what they were driving for was to save people's souls, so that people wouldn't burn in hell, so that people would go to heaven. It was all about that. There wasn't anything about, necessarily, making your life better.
我认为只要他们意识到，他们所追求的总和就是拯救人们的灵魂，这样人们就不会在地狱中燃烧，这样人们就会去天堂。完全是为了那个。没有关于，必然地，让你的生活变得更好。
This is Ralph's beef with a purely emotional service. Religion, he says, should give you real help with your everyday problems.
这就是拉尔夫对纯情感礼拜的不满。他说，宗教应该在你处理日常问题时给予你真正的帮助。
It's not that we wait and it all gets sorted out before the judgment seat on some great day in the future. It's here and now, this stuff is supposed to work.
并不是我们等待一切在未来某个伟大的日子审判座前得到解决。就在此时此地，这些东西应该起作用。
I mean, where I grew up, we were in a lower middle class situation, people living really difficult lives. If somebody had a difficult life that-- you know, a woman whose husband was running around on her, that wasn't addressed in church at all, except we might pray for his soul that he would get saved, he would get right. The whole deal was, get your soul right with God.
我是说，我长大的地方，我们在中下阶层的情况下，人们过着非常艰难的生活。如果有人生活艰难，那就是——你知道，一个丈夫在外面胡搞的女人，那根本没有在教堂里解决，除非我们可能会为他的灵魂祈祷，祈求他得救，他会变好。整个事情就是，让你的灵魂在上帝面前变好。
The question I kept asking the congregants over and over at Bethel was, since he wasn't exactly their ideal type of minister, had they ever thought of getting rid of Ralph, like the white churches did? But everyone I asked gave me sort of a curious look, like I was asking a really strange question. Before Ralph, Bethel hadn't really had a preacher in 30 years. And once they got Ralph Hutchison, they weren't going to let him go. It hadn't even occurred to them to get rid of him. He was theirs.
我一直在伯特利反复问会众的一个问题是，因为他并不是他们心目中理想的牧师类型，他们有没有想过像白人教堂那样摆脱拉尔夫？但我问的每个人都给了我一种奇怪的表情，好像我在问一个非常奇怪的问题。在拉尔夫之前，伯特利已经30年没有传教士了。一旦他们有了拉尔夫·哈奇森，他们就不会让他走。他们甚至没想过要摆脱他。他是他们的。
We really don't have much choice, meaning in the Presbyterian field, the Presbyterian church field, there's not that many black ministers. So we take what we can get, and it just happened to be a white minister.
我们真的没太多选择，意思是说在长老会领域，长老会教堂领域，没那么多黑人牧师。所以我们能得到什么就接受什么，而刚好是一位白人牧师。
For his part, Ralph agrees that Bethel might be better off with a black minister.
就拉尔夫而言，他同意伯特利如果有一位黑人牧师可能会更好。
Well, I think there's a number of reasons why it would be nice if they were able to have an African-American minister. It's still something the Presbytery should talk about. They shouldn't assume that Bethel has nobody or they get a bleeding heart liberal white preacher to work part-time. There ought to be more possibilities than that. They should have him, and I should get out of the way so they can.
嗯，我认为如果他们能拥有一位非裔美国人牧师，那会很好，原因有很多。这仍然是长老会应该谈论的事情。他们不应该假设伯特利没人，或者他们找一个热血自由派白人传教士来兼职。应该有比这更多的可能性。他们应该有他，我应该让开，这样他们就可以拥有他。
Laying it all out like this, I think it might sound gloomier than it really is. The congregants at Bethel are getting everything they want from church. They get the Word of God from Ralph, the Spirit of God from other churches, and a feeling of congregation from each other.
把这一切都摆出来，我认为它听起来可能比实际情况更阴郁。伯特利的会众正从教会得到他们想要的一切。他们从拉尔夫那里得到上帝的话语，从其他教会得到上帝的精神，并从彼此那里感受到会众的感觉。
Susie Putz-Drury in Campbellsville, Tennessee.
苏西·普茨-德鲁里在田纳西州坎贝尔斯维尔。
Well, our program was produced today by Wendy Dorr and myself with Alex Blumberg, Jonathan Goldstein, Starlee Kine, and Diane Cook. Senior producer Julie Snyder. Music help from Mr. John Connors.
好了，我们的节目今天由温迪·多尔和我自己制作，还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、乔纳森·戈德斯坦、斯塔莉·凯恩和黛安·库克。高级制片人朱莉·斯奈德。约翰·康纳斯先生提供了音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
[鸣谢]
If you'd like to buy a cassette of this or any of our programs, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380, or visit our website. Or you can do that, or you can listen to our programs for free, www.thisamericanlife.org, right there.
如果你想购买这个或我们任何节目的磁带，请致电我们在芝加哥的WBEZ电台，312-832-3380，或访问我们的网站。或者你可以那样做，或者你可以免费收听我们的节目，www.thisamericanlife.org，就在那里。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia. His ways are mysterious. None can know them. He keeps commanding us--
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责。他的方式是神秘的。没人能知道它们。他一直命令我们——
Go to Peoria. Give away all you possess and go to Peoria.
去皮奥里亚。放弃你拥有的一切，去皮奥里亚。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。